so tell me about you what what do what  do you do I teach kindergarten that's  such a delicate thing right you give the  kids something and then B yeah they have  it forever yellow house it's loosely the  same food guy  was that a pole I was at home the Sun  hits her yellow house it is almost like  a sign from God  Wow with so few elements take something  very very complex I think we have a  young motor if you stay curious  [Music]  I've asked Jimmy to recite a few of his  poem was at a poetry reading forget it  on Thursday he has baseball practice  with his friend he's gifted mr. Roy and  I want my son to have a normal life  Jimmy hi  [Music]  laughter town is fragile that's so rare  and our culture does everything to crush  it Jimmy push it to the left Mozart was  nurtured by kings and queens they  massaged his tired hands they fed him  candy  recite your bones  as your me  you